a friend first and foremost to us not
just a colleague a friend Michael
Douglas Dean but Mickey Mickey Deane to
all of us brave as a lion but what what
a heart what a human being you know
you're never supposed to talk ill of the
dead it would not be possible to talk he
loved Mickey it's just positive all the
way 62 a husband to Daniela a father to
Patrick and Ben to us a cameraman and a
friend but I one of the reasons I always
loved going out with them is that the
first thing when you go on a trip is you
know Cade say which was the cameraman
was going on and when you knew it was
Nick it was great because he was going
to be fun and be is going to be
professional and he was what I call a
cameraman journalist there's some great
camera can take great pictures and think
was one of them but there was also these
guys they were journalists you didn't
have to tell him that the president
walking out of power sex in country why
what they look like he knew because he
followed the news because he was a
journalist but that's just the work
that's just the work stuff Mickey was
humorous to the nth degree in a very dry
way but he was also wise and he kept his
counsel and when you're on the road with
small teams and difficult circumstances
people that are both humorous and can
keep their counsel are diamonds and gems
to be with but when he gave his counsel
it was worth listening to to us a friend
our hearts go out to his family and he
died doing what he done so brilliantly
for so many decades